So what answers did you come up with,
David?
>> So we knew that because the boat
is traveling from the right back to
the left, that the boat is going to be
on the left in each of the next states,
so we didn't even ask for that.
In the top state, the only things we
could do are move both people back,
just the guard back, or
just the prisoner back.
Moving both back would just take
us back to our original state, so
while it's legal, it's not productive.
Moving just our prisoner back would have
more prisoners on the left than guards,
so that wouldn't be a legal move.
So our only move is to move
our guard back to the left.
Similarly on the bottom, we could either
move both prisoners back to the left, or
just one.
Moving both would take us back to our
original state which isn't productive.
Moving just one, then,
is our only legal next state.
>> That was a good answer, David.
Thank you.
Note David, that these two
states that he came up with,
the one at the top here and one at
the bottom here, are in fact identical.
And because they're identical, therefore
we can collapse them into one state.
So, now we get the representation
shown in this figure,
the two states have been
collapsed into one.
>> So in this semantic network, we don't
really care how we got into a state,
just as long as we know
what state we're in.
And that makes sense in this
problem solving process.
Once we're in this state, we don't
care if we got to it this way, or
this way, all we care about is
the current state of the problem.